jean marc civette bonjour alors pour le
président de la banque de france
l'économie française devrait mettre deux
ans pour se relever de la pandémie est
la banque de france table sur une
récession de 9% à la fin de l'année à
bruno le maire lui est plus pessimiste
parce qu'il travaille sur une hypothèse
de baisse du pib de 11% avec un risque
de chômage massif à partir de septembre
où on pourrait atteindre un pic de
chômeurs de 11 millions alors comment se
fait-il que la france est un pays
d'europe à avoir plongé le plus comme
cela oui alors c'est vrai que si on se
compare à l'allemagne aux pays nordiques
ou même aux états unis on se désole si
on se compare à l'italie et à l'espagne
on se console un petit peu enfin
l'europe est coupé en deux le nord qui
va perdre cinq à six points de
croissance dans l'année
et puis l'europe du sud qui va perdre
plus du double en moyenne 10% alors
pourquoi a t'on plongée que si gravement
et bien parce que le confinement a été
ces belda été respectée nous avions des
problèmes auparavant que nous n'avions
pas réglée et donc qu'on retrouve
maintenant et notre économie est une
économie aussi qui est dominé par les
services c'est à dire l'assurance
d'abord le tourisme surtout et les
services et bien sûr fonder sur les
rapports humains et ça eh ben ça c'est
arrêté des usines industrielles ont
continué de tourner et l'allemagne a
confiné mais l'allemagne a continué de
travailler plus que dans l'europe du sud
l'allemagne avaient des masques la même
l'allemagne avait des tests n'avions
donc pas on s'est enfermés dans un
climat d'angoissé terrible qui fait qu'
on hésite beaucoup d'ailleurs on a
beaucoup hésité à ceux des confidents
vous vous souvenez ya trois semaines
beaucoup hésité à sortir beaucoup
refusaient même de mettre leurs enfants
à l'école beaucoup avaient peur et vous
aviez même des syndicats qui
recommandait à ses adhérents le droit de
retrait on a vu ça chez renault la
france a eu un problème au début de
l'épidémie parce qu'elle n'était pas
préparée qu'elle n'était pas équipée la
france a un problème aujourd'hui un peu
denses déconfinement j'ajoute que le
déconfinement révèle c'est ça la
caractéristique française des
entreprises qui avaient déjà des
problèmes avant et que ces problèmes se
sont aggravés
d'où ces prévisions qui sont très
alarmantes alors même que les blancs des
de soutien et sont récents sont bâtis
sont très généreux vous savez nous
sommes les champions du monde du chômage
partiel
17h chômage partiel qui ne détruit pas
l'appareil de production puisque le
contrat de travail et mat et nous sommes
les champions du monde des prêts
garantis par l'état plus de 100
milliards d'euros encore 10 milliards
pour airbus et air france la vérité
c'est qu'au delà du match ne peut pas se
remettre au boulot et à reconnaître
qu'ils avaient des difficultés à bord la
banque de france 1 qui espère aussi que
les français vont vont dépenser leur
argent qu'ils entendaient parler
absolument pour le gouverneur de la
banque de france est un peu le noeud du
problème mais je pense qu'il a il a
raison la consommation est un bon moteur
de la reprise et les français ont mis de
côté presque 100 milliards d'euros au
départ c'est de l'argent qui sert à
grand chose en fait
on espère que cet argent va revenir en
consommation dans le circuit économique
mais on peut pas obliger les gens à à
changer de voiture 6 ans n'ont pas envie
hein c'était pas mal c'est une épargne
de la peur c'est une épargne de la
précaution chez les français qui ont
peur que le virus hogan s'est pas exclu
et qui ont surtout peur aussi de perdre
leur job à la rentrée de septembre
alors plus concrètement quand on garde
un petit peu en arrière on s'aperçoit
avec la france rentre toujours plus
lentement que les autres dans une crise
elle plonge aussi plus que les autres et
donc elle a du mal à en sortir pourquoi
cette difficulté ça c'est très très
franco-français un notre économie donne
des grands coups d'accordéon
c'est vrai qu'en l'an 2000 c'était vrai
en 2008 2009 avec la crise financière la
sat est très présente
puis c'est vrai aujourd'hui avec à
chaque fois un risque de tsunami
politique et social parce que ça tangue
le premier facteur c'est que depuis
vingt ans on a eu du mal à s'adapter aux
grandes mutations internationales la
mondialisation en a eu peur
le digital on en a un peu peur aussi
donc on est en retard sur l'allemagne on
est en retard par rapport aux principaux
pays développés manque de compétitivité
pour affronter cette concurrence
internationale
donc là encore ça tangue le deuxième
facteur c'est que nous avons des frais
généraux qui sont très lo l'état coûte
cher l'administration coûte cher les
services publics coûtent cher l'hôpital
coûte cher l'éducation nationale coûte
cher et quand je dis qu'elles coûtent
cher
cher toutes choses égales par ailleurs
par rapport à nos concurrents et ça
marche pas très bien c'est bien ça on a
bien vu sur l'hôpital on voit sur les
buts et national
donc nous sommes champions du monde de
la dépense publique donc beaucoup
d'impôts beaucoup de chars pour un
résultat qui est pas top quand même
alors selon on aurait besoin ce sont des
investissements de compétitivité on a
besoin de prendre des risques
on aurait besoin d'avoir confiance
troisième facteur c'est que nous avons
un modèle social qui est exceptionnel
exceptionnel on s'en aperçoit pas on de
mal reconnaître mais il amortit les
crises
il permet les perfusions il permet des
prestations c'est ce qui permet de
rentrer plus tard d'ailleurs on retarde
l'entrée dans la crise
mais ce modèle nous incite pas à en
sortir en plus on le sait il coûte cher
et qui nous empêche donc de courir assez
vite
j'ajouterai que l'état qui gère tout est
centralisé il est donc assez peu réactif
il est très protecteur très providence
assez plus réactif on l'a vu avec la
crise un c nous n'avons pas cette
culture du risque
or le progrès qu il passe très souvent
par le risque il fallait prendre le
risque de déconfinement et de les
confiner assez vite et assez haut tout
ça ne fait que notre résilience comme on
dit aujourd'hui c'est à dire notre
capacité à rebondir est faible alors
faut pas trop exagérer non plus la
france a d'énormes qualités elle a
d'énormes opportunités il fait bon vivre
comme quand ça va bien elle a du
potentiel du génie même à tel point que
la france est avec trois pays au monde
d'aujourd'hui qui est le plus attractif
pour les investisseurs étrangers
donc il faudrait peut-être parfois on
s'arrête dès qu'on arrête de se plaindre
merci beaucoup jean marc sylvestre
d'avoir été avec nous ce matin sur rtl
france rappelle que vous êtes
journaliste éditorialiste économique
merci beaucoup